Hoje vamos aprender uma das ideias mais importantes desta formação.
Chama-se acima da linha e abaixo da linha.
É muito simples, mas pode mudar a forma como trabalha, como comunica e como cresce.
Nos próximos minutos, quero que se lembra apenas de uma pergunta.
Estou acima da linha ou abaixo da linha?
É só isso.
Apenas uma pergunta.
Estou acima da linha ou abaixo da linha?
Todos os dias algo acontece, comete-se um erro, uma máquina varia-se, alguém chega atrasado,
alguém discorda de si.
A situação é a mesma, mas as pessoas reagem de forma diferente.
Algumas pessoas vão para abaixo da linha, outras mantem-se acima da linha.
A situação é a mesma, a diferença está na forma como reagem.
Comecemos por abaixo da linha.
Quando estamos abaixo da linha, culpamos os outros.
Arrangemos desculpas.
Ficamos defensivos.
Deixamos de ouvir.
Queixámos-nos.
Dizemos, a culpa não foi minha.
Foram eles que causaram problema.
Outra pessoa que resolva.
Abaixo da linha é sobre protegermos a nós próprios.
Não é sobre aprender.
Não é sobre melhorar.
É sobre proteger o nosso ego.
Vamos repetir isto.
Abaixo da linha, culpa, desculpas,
postura defensiva.
Outra vez, culpa, desculpas,
Se só se lembrar destas três palavras, já aprendeu algo valioso.
Agora vejamos acima da linha.
Acima da linha é diferente.
Acima da linha pergunta o que posso aprender.
O que posso fazer?
Como posso ajudar?
Acima da linha escuta.
Acima da linha faz perguntas.
Acima da linha aceita feedback.
Acima da linha procura soluções.
Acima da linha assume responsabilidade.
Vamos repetir isto.
Acima da linha, fazer perguntas, escutar,
aceitar feedback, assumir responsabilidade,
procurar soluções.
Outra vez, fazer perguntas, escutar,
aceitar feedback, assumir responsabilidade,
procurar soluções.
Estes são os hábitos das pessoas que continuam a crescer.
Imagine duas pessoas.
Acontece o mesmo erro.
A primeira pessoa diz quem causou isto.
A segunda pessoa diz como resolvemos isto.
Qual das duas pessoas acha que aprende mais?
Qual delas danha mais confiança?
Qual delas se torna o melhor líder?
A resposta é simples.
A pessoa que se mantém, acima da linha.
Agora, há algo importante.
Estar acima da linha não significa ser perfeito.
Toda a gente comete erros.
Toda a gente sente frustração.
Toda a gente vai parar abaixo da linha de vez em quando.
Toda a gente.
O objetivo não é ser perfeito.
O objetivo é dar por isso.
Quanto mais depressa se aperceber,
mais depressa consegue voltar para acima da linha.
O primeiro passo é a consciência.
Repare onde está.
O segundo passo é a escolha.
Escolha a mover-se para acima da linha.
O terceiro passo é o crescimento.
Quando repete isto todos os dias,
torna-se melhor todos os dias.
Abaixo da linha.
Culpa, desculpas.
Postura defensiva.
Queixas, problemas.
Acima da linha.
Responsabilidade, perguntas.
Feedback, escuta.
Soluções.
Vamos lê-las mais uma vez.
Abaixo da linha.
Culpa, desculpas.
Postura defensiva.
Queixas, problemas.
Acima da linha.
Responsabilidade, perguntas.
Feedback, escuta.
Soluções.
Lembre-se delas.
Vão ajudá-lo todos os dias.
No trabalho, em casa, em todas as relações.
Por isso, antes de terminarmos,
quero que se lembre de uma pergunta.
Sempre que algo correr mal,
sempre que alguém lhe der feedback,
sempre que cometer um erro,
pare um momento.
E pergunte a si mesmo.
Estou acima da linha ou abaixo da linha?
Pergunte outra vez.
Porque cada vez que escolhe acima da linha,
torna-se um pouco mais sábio,
um pouco mais forte,
um pouco mais digno de confiança
e um pouco mais bem sucedido.
Na próxima lição,
vamos aprender o primeiro hábito de viver acima da linha
e como pode começar a praticá-lo todos os dias.